foreign as we all celebrate Black
History Month California is making
history of its own it's a first date to
create reparations task force to study
how slavery and systemic racism have
harmed black Americans in this country
now the group is almost finished a final
proposal outlining what compensation
should look like and who would be able
to benefit Don basiano was one of the
many people who told their stories of
racial Injustice to this task force she
shared how her ancestors came to Coloma
California that's a Gold Rush town as
enslaved people they gain their freedom
and they worked very hard to buy more
than 400 acres of land which included a
gold Discovery site then the state
seized it under imminent domain so
instead of being passed down through her
family the land was turned into the
Marshall goal Discovery State Historic
Park we met bassiano on that land and
she told us what reparations would look
like for her
foreign
being able to look around and see all
this is mine
you know I own this this is within my
family
I wouldn't have to worry about am I
going to have enough when I retire where
am I going to be you know financially
what are things going to look like that
wouldn't be a concern and that's reality
when you talk about generational wealth
and that generational wealth was ripped
away
pearly Monroe is my great
grandfather and he planted most of the
trees that you see here
slavery was here it wasn't like the
South but it was here my
great-grandmother Evelyn Binion married
pearly Monroe in 1931 and pearly Monroe
is the grandson of Nancy and Peter gooch
Nancy and Peter came to California
slaves to work in the mines
when California became a state they were
allowed their freedom
Nancy started making money for herself
she sewed she cooked her and her husband
Peter bought some 20 30 acres of land
out here in Coloma and from there just
continued to buy more land
[Music]
Coloma was was at one point essentially
a black town there were black business
owners here you know they owned homes
property
when folks outside saw that the land had
some value that's when you see the shift
and you see it slowly moving from this
place where black families lived to you
know white families coming in and
displacing them
foreign
Acres was actually taken through eminent
domain
it hurts it hurts because pearly fought
so hard
to keep this land up here you weren't to
court he tried to fight and You Know It
ultimately he wasn't able to keep
anything
and it hurts to walk up here and and see
what he saw touch what he may have
touched they never lived here they owned
it but they never lived here it was it
was strictly for rental property
and it's just something that should have
stayed within the family and it didn't
so I almost want to go around the entire
house and just touch everything you know
if he was not forced to give up his land
we would still be living up here
enjoying everything that's here the
river the water
the trees would not look the way that
they do now
[Music]
these trees should be bearing fruit you
know
we need some truth behind what's
displayed and what's told but the story
is that he sold you see that in many
many places oh no pearly sold the land
to the state no they came and took the
land
say it it was taken through imminent
domain
you know you have to dig for it to learn
who lived here and who and that slavery
even existed here
reparations for me looks like getting
what pieces of the park that here that
the state owns returned to the family
and then
the full and true story
being told you know
that story of my family
that's what reparations looks like for
me
[Music]
Don bossiano was not the only person
who's claiming that her family was
forced to sell their land to build this
state park there were other black
families that have come forward as well
the reparations task force is
recommending that the state now create
an agency which would process and
cooperate claims for reparations
California's governor gave the task
force until July to recommend what
compensation would look like and more
importantly who would qualify I think a
big shout out and thank you to Don
basiano for telling that story because I
think it's confusing for a lot of people
what is it how would it work but when
she lays it out the way she did you can
really understand why people feel hey
this wasn't right yes it's important to
listen to these stories exactly sure is
we will be right back